I would suggest,
and I wonder whether you agree that one
thing we can do is actually live up to
the ideals that we profess to live by
and that we professed,
that these countries also should live by
and just to take an example,
the history of our engagement and the
Arabian peninsula over the last hundred
years is a history of promising freedom
and democracy,
but in fact doing everything to make
sure that they could never possibly work
because we always put the interests of
commercial convenience above the
interest of those ideals and we
continue.
I pledged to do so in that we allow BA
systems or bp or our dependence on oil
to come before actually supporting
Republican nationalist secular
governments in the Middle East and we've
always been terrified of them.
So isn't there much more we can do than
just have better chats on the ground?
Can't we actually be true to our ideals?
Yes,
we can do much better to be true to our
ideals.
I mean,
the history of Britain's involvement in
the Middle East since the first world
war is,
is shameful what we did after the
collapse of the Ottoman Empire.
The way we connived with the Syrian
French colony.
The way we created a colony in Iraq was
shameful.
So yes,
we can,
but and this is another thing,
let's not be so carried away with an
illusory nature of what we are.
Our allies are or can be into the bigger
danger,
which is that we talk so much about our
ideals.
We lived the dream of our principals so
much that we raised the expectation of
people in other countries in ways that
were unable to fulfill.
Probably the thing that actually hits me
hardest about Iraq
was that our presence there on the
ground and my experience than me son,
is that the more I talked about human
rights,
the more I talked about our principles,
the more encouraged people to come
forward.
Haida who worked with me as my
translator or women who joined our
provincial council,
who would subsequently killed by the
militia and who we've done absolutely
nothing to protect or,
or to get out of the country because we
did what we couldn't do.
We exceeded our resources,
we made promises we couldn't fulfill and
we raised expectations which we were
unable to do anything about.
So I think that's almost the crueler the
trail.